[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
hey this is Steve mcdabble lab welcome
to where are we day 3 of 5 on the live
stream for building Alexa skills for for
anybody that was here the first couple
of days welcome back for anybody who's
new welcome we are going today to let me
switch over here we are going to first
we're gonna just start with a recap of
what we talked about yesterday where am
I here we go so um quick recap yesterday
we we did an intro to the Alexa skills
kit CLI and we also looked at the Alexa
skills kit sdk 2.0 2.0 and we talked to
ok and we talked about coding intent
handlers and we created a couple of
handlers in our example application that
we started building which is or example
skill rather which is a skill for free
code camp that we're hoping to use as a
live example but we'll we'll see how it
goes and then toward the end of
yesterday we started working on wiring
up some code to call an external API and
specifically what I was trying to do was
to get a list of the Articles that are
posted on the free code camp median site
and ran into an issue so we didn't
finish that up but that's a good segue
into what we're gonna do today because
we're going to talk about debugging so
I'm gonna just pick up where I left off
yesterday bugs and all and and try to
continue on from there so today we are
gonna do a an intro to debugging to
start it out and then we're going to
talk about the the skill manifest and
we're gonna end today with a discussion
on beta testing and hopefully provide
anybody that wants to do this an
opportunity to to test the skill in test
on their end and I am also I didn't do
this but I meant to set up a github repo
for this stuff
today so I'll I'll do that before
tomorrow so anybody that wants to pull
the code will be able to do that so
let's let's get into let's get into it
if me let me go back to where we left
off exactly yesterday so if you recall
from yesterday if you were on if you if
you weren't on let me just walk through
what we did quickly yesterday and then
I'm gonna start with testing the skill
and we're gonna get the same error and
then I'm gonna go through how we would
go about debugging that error so
yesterday we created let's see where we
left off was this recent articles intent
handler and this is where I was getting
the the error so I was trying to use
this NPM module to to pull a JSON feed
from medium and was getting an error so
let's let's just let me just get over
back over here and we'll start where we
left off so let's see I did so I'm gonna
redeploy the lambda function and let's
so Alexa open free code camp
alexxa open free code camp okay welcome
to the free code camp skill I can tell
you about recent medium articles or
scheduled live streams what would you
like medium articles okay so this is the
error that we are getting a lexis stop
and I'm Anna Alexis stop goodbye so I
want to show you a couple of different
ways we could do a whole well maybe not
a week maybe a week on just debugging in
error working through errors so I'm
gonna just touch on a couple of the the
easiest or the most straightforward ways
to go at it so with the the new SDK when
an error is thrown like I'm using in
this year using promises and when an
error occurs somewhere in here it
triggers this there's like an error
handler this air handler down here and
by default with this template that we
used it just says this sorry I can't
understand the command please try again
what I do sometimes I mean it's just
kind of a cheat but while I'm developing
you wouldn't want to do this in a live
skill but I'll just do something like
this
[Music]
and this way I'm gonna redeploy the
lambda function this way when the error
occurs it's going to I'm gonna be able
to hear what the error message was this
can be a quick hack to quickly figure
out without digging through the logs
what's going on but Alexa open free code
camp median articles the earrings
could not find handler that can handle
the request type intent request
requested API request dot one day 71-62
d6 1850 1946 Alexa stop so if you got
that so let me so that wasn't actually
the error that I thought we were getting
but let me let me try something else
Alexa open free code camp that error it
just didn't find the utterance medium
posts okay it like to stop so from that
Alexa stop goodbye from that I can I can
guess what the the problem is but I want
to show you how else you would get to it
so you can go through and look at the
logs for the lambda function and you can
you can also see in the code here let's
see
in the air function you see by default
it logs to the council and so if you go
into your lambda function and then go to
monitoring and then from here jump out
to the logs and this is loading taking a
second well this load I'm gonna read
some of the comments which ie I'm using
the IDE I'm using is Visual Studio code
you can go to code Visual Studio comm to
grab that it's open source and I like it
a lot
why does it always say free code camp
skill I'm not sure I understand that
question
can you Karthik can you um can you try
to clarify that let's see okay
back to back to this and I'll come back
to that
so in here a lot of times what I'll do
is just go to text because it's easier
to read but in here I can see that error
that got written out the error handled
here in an assignment to constant
variable so I've got a an error it's a
JavaScript error I'm trying to reassign
a value to a constant so I should have
declared the variable with something
other than Const and if you're if you're
not familiar with with with JavaScript
there's actually if you go to well
there's a lot of tutorials on free code
camps YouTube channel and then I did one
also that's sort of in the context of
doing Alexa development and if you go to
youtube.com slash dabble lab there's a
note j/s intro to node.js for developing
Alexa skills and what the first video or
first or second video I think talks
about variables and
so let's go see where that problem is so
in this handler here yeah so here's the
problem
so I declared this speech Tex as a
constant and I'm trying to reset the
value of that constant down here and
that I think is probably what's causing
the the issue but let's see so right now
just for testing what I'm doing here is
grabbing the the very first record so
it's an array that comes back of posts
medium posts and I'm just trying to grab
the title from the first one so let's re
deploy this and see if that fixes it
yeah yeah that's I see what you're
asking now about why it keeps saying
free code camp that's just this here
this could be anything yeah in fact you
had some you I'll say Phoenix you had
some really good suggestions for content
tomorrow's or yesterday so I think we're
gonna grab some of those and use them to
clean this up in a little bit so let's
some let's test this now that that's all
deployed so Alexa open free code camp
Alexa open free code camp welcome to
camp skill I can tell you about recent
medium articles or scheduled live
streams what would you like medium
articles how I built a job scraping web
app using yoga j/s okay so now it's
working now we we got the we got the
array from medium and we got the first
item in the array and we got the title
so we'll need to clean this up and
respond with something a little more
meaningful to the user but we've got at
least the the bones of the code working
so I'm gonna leave that for right now
and transition to I want to try to by
the end of the day today and I jumped
around in my plan I recapped what we
talked about yesterday but I knew I
didn't really get into everything that I
want to talk about today so so today I
want to get into like I said debugging
which we just started talking about and
the skill manifest in beta testing but
I'd like to also clean the skill up a
little bit so it's less hack together
and a little more polished so we'll do
that today as well
coming back over here
the the last point I want to make on
debugging and this is like super simple
debugging is you can debug in the in the
console through developer amazon.com
also and let me show you that so well
actually through the AWS console but I'm
gonna get the request I'm gonna get the
request from inside the Alexa developer
console let me just grab that real quick
and I'll show you here
[Music]
[Music]
okay so in here and I'm not good
although you can test we talked about
this on the first day you can test in
here but what I'm doing right now is I'm
not really going in here to test as much
as I'm going in here to to get the
example of a request and then I'm gonna
use that to test why my internet it's
really really slow or something here
okay
so now I didn't get the error here
because we fixed it but what I'm what
I'm doing is I'm just copying this
request Jason here the other way that I
could test is I could go over here to
the function and I think I talked about
this on the first day actually too so
this might be a this might be a review
but just in case so here in the land of
function you can go test and then paste
the jason in here and i'm gonna create
that as a test and then i can run the
test here which right now it's gonna
succeed so no nothing's going wrong but
if i change this back and recreate that
that error which was where was it
[Music]
show you the last piece of testing here
so okay so I'm redeploying the lambda
now but I'm really just redeploying it
to recreate that error and like I said I
mean there's better ways we could do a
whole course on testing then what I'm
showing you right now but this is the
quickest way to to get started with it
so so if I run the test now I get the
response back but I can also go down
here and I can see that council log info
here so without having to dig through
the log files so that's just another way
to to quickly figure out what's going on
if you're getting errors as you're doing
developing so three different ways you
can go through the cloud watch log files
for the lambda function you can use
simulated test like use an example
request or you can the third way in the
first way that we talked about is in the
error intent handler you can just wire
this up to read back the the message the
error message that's coming in you can
usually figure out what's going on from
that again you don't want to leave that
in there when the skill goes live but
three different ways to go at it all
right any any questions at this point
before I move on let me read real quick
here
yeah so it looks like Karthik's got the
questions covered Thank You kardec
okay all right well let's um let's keep
let's keep rolling let's keep moving on
so the next thing I want to do is I want
to clean this up a little bit we're
doing fine on time we were just at 20
minutes into it so we've got got some
time yesterday we had a lot of really
good suggestions that you guys provided
for some things that we could add to it
and I tried to make some notes from the
the log and some of the things that some
of the ideas that that came back were I
think just just clean up the the intro
altogether so I'm gonna use this was
provided by Phoenix who's on right now
so I think we want to include this you
know something that says what is free
code cam and then a lot of these ideas I
think we could boil into just sort of
FAQ kind of functionality and so I think
that's probably the way to handle all of
the not all of them but most of them
some of them though like how many hours
of content are on YouTube
this one the the answer is variable
because that'll be changing so we'll
probably want to figure out how to get
that from an API if we did that and the
multi turn dialogue we're gonna do this
I am thinking that we will probably get
two to that on here's here's my plan for
the rest of the week so a day for will
we'll get into using slots and custom
slots and we'll we'll do that in entity
resolution so I'm gonna save the FAQ
adding the FAQ for tomorrow because I
think we can do a whole day on that
and then day five which will be Friday
this Friday we'll talk about using multi
turn dialogues and then also I think
talking about saving information to
DynamoDB is something that we ought to
cover and then this certification
process if we have the skill ready and
it's okay with free code camp maybe we
can actually submit it for a
certification I thought maybe we could
do that to that I don't think we're
gonna be able to do that but what we can
do is the beta test and so we'll go
through that process right now actually
so we talked about debugging the skill
manifest is the the next thing that
we're gonna talk about right now so in
the in the developer Council when we
went through this on day one we talked
through creating the interaction model
and providing all of the skill
configuration information through the
web browser but all of this can be
configured as part of your skill project
and it is all of the details are in this
file here for them well most of them are
the like we talked about the invocation
name and the model stuff is is in here
but the the details for the skill are in
here and the the example that is
provided with the default template the
greeter template that is what we started
with doesn't provide everything that you
would need to to complete the submission
if you were going to submit it for
certification but the I've got that in
well actually any one of the if you use
one of the templates from skill
templates com I've we've added those in
there so the skill Jason so for example
the icon URLs and I'll just
grap these for right now just to show
you and we'll also will also need just
as an example so in the documentation
you can get an example of all of the
different options that are available
here for the manifest file the
configuration stuff or you can use that
at most of what's required at least for
custom skills is in actually all of
what's required for custom skills is in
the start up template examples so you
can use those as well and the repo will
be on github I meant to put it out there
today for this code but I'll definitely
have it out by tomorrow let's see in
this privacy and compliance stuff here
we need
[Music]
which isn't included I guess for obvious
reasons
[Music]
you need your own privacy policy and
everything but so now and then of course
we would want to go through here and
finish up the summary short description
and we'll say a skill for free code camp
I'm sure somebody can come up with
something better than this and then for
the example phrases we want to update
this too
and I'll say we ask free code camp yeah
or recent recent medium posts and ask
free code camp or what was the other one
we were gonna do let's see let's go back
to our dialogue notes from yesterday
what the most as free code camp what the
most recent videos are
[Music]
and yeah then we would want a more
detailed description all of this stuff
is what is going to show up in the
public skill store so so when the when a
user goes and searches for skills in the
Alexa companion app or in this skill
store they're gonna show up here so well
let me just grab Jeopardy to show you so
this is the the skill name here you can
see and then the example phrases or
what's showing up here and then the
longer description is is this here
alright that is what we're setting up in
here so once some once this is all
configured in key words are in here too
so there's there's more than what I'm
gonna do but just for for time today
I'm not gonna go out and or I'm not
gonna fill all this out but you would
want to before you publish it live but
we're gonna go ahead and deploy this and
this time I'm not gonna use the dash t
because I do want to deploy the changes
to the skill and rebuild the interaction
model so we use the full deploy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah any ideas for what we ought to
include in the skill keep those keep
those coming out go through tomorrow and
pull out new ideas and we'll try to get
as much of this in as we can and that'll
be maybe maybe there will be a little
bit of time today I don't want to spend
time just updating content because I
don't want to save as much time as we
can for actually doing some coding stuff
but what I'm gonna do next is I'm gonna
show you how to set up beta testing for
a skill and then for anybody that has an
echo that would like to to debate a test
this I have a let's see had a a URL to a
Google Form let me grab that real quick
[Music]
and I'll post that in the in the
comments so if you want to you can just
provide your your your email address and
I'll invite you to to beta test it so
that you can test it on your echo if you
want to do that okay so now that it's
all deployed let's go back over here and
take a look at the changes okay so we're
gonna go over here to certification and
and the certification process we're not
gonna go live yet but what we are gonna
do is and this has changed just a little
bit so this functional test looks new
okay so this is this is different that
isn't what I meant that isn't what I
wanted let me withdraw that what I
wanted was the
[Music]
okay that's perfect okay so I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna have to figure out
what's going on there
Alexa open free code camp welcome to the
free code camp skill I can tell you
about recent medium articles or
scheduled live streams what would you
like
median articles the earner is assignment
to constant variable Alexa stop goodbye
okay
[Music]
yeah so this is this stuff was set with
the manifest in here and used to be that
like very recently okay it looks like
this is letting me with dry let's see
[Music]
all right we're gonna I'm gonna come
back to this cuz something's changed
here it used to be that you could send
it through beta test and I'm not seeing
that now so I need to figure out why so
let's um here's our icons came through
this time which is good all right I'm
gonna come back to that let's let's keep
keep going here I'm not sure where that
went
I'm guessing it's probably been probably
been moved but I'll have to figure that
out okay the so I guess we can we've
still got time so we're why don't we
just go ahead and move into some of what
I wanted to talk about on day four and
we will talk about using slots how about
we do that all right
the distribution tab all right let me
actually let me go back to this
[Music]
oh I see I didn't finish this up okay
here it here's what I was looking for
all right so the beta test here is where
you would enter your email address as
the admin and then down here you would
add the email addresses of anybody that
you wanted to have as a tester as a beta
tester and so the email address that you
that you provide here needs to be an
email address that they're using with
their Amazon echo so it needs to be an
Amazon account but I will do as an
example I'll do one to Karthik and add
him but anybody else I'll post in the
post in the chat a link like I said to
the here we go Google Form
[Music]
and then if you want to be a beta tester
I'll add you to this so there is there's
the link so anybody that wants to get a
beta test invite I'll I'll do that after
the the stream today but you'll be able
to enable the skill and you'll just see
how that whole process works so if you
haven't done it before you'll see what
it looks like on the the beta test side
of it so that yeah that thank you
Ken for that direction I was lost
appreciate that okay
yeah we've still got we've still got
twenty minutes so let's let's let's keep
going let me look to see if there's any
questions for a second and then we will
move on
okay all right yeah let's keep going
let's go into let's go into using slots
so I'm going to I'm gonna use I because
we've got a lot of what the ideas that
we had a lot of the functionality is
kind of FAQ ish I thought like we could
maybe just set up an FAQ within this
skill and actually there is a new skill
template that we had been working on
they see if it is out there I think it
is it has some really similar
functionality so I'm gonna grab that
remember from yesterday ask new template
URL skill templates
calm / templates Jason and it's this one
here this knowledgebase starter and this
one has this is this is basically an FAQ
skill so I'll show you the code and then
we'll grab we'll grab some of the the
code here and merge it into our free
code camp skill so what what's going on
here there's two things I want to show
you the model first of all so when we
talked quickly day one about slots
I mentioned that slots are kind of
parameters so during a dialogue between
the user and the skill the oftentimes
the the intent is going to need
information from the user to fulfill
whatever it is that you want to do and
so the the information or the parameters
that the skill is going to use are
called slots and there's basically two
different types of slots there's built
in slots and then there's custom slot
types so built-in slots over here
and we're gonna do this using the ask
CLI what I'm not gonna change anything
in here but I'm just gonna show you in
here so in here we've got our intents
and we'll just actually no I said I'm
not going to do that and then there
there's also slots and there's if I
create a slot here well let me get out
here and choose add that way I won't
have to add it so there's two different
kinds of slots there's custom slots and
then there is built-in slots and the
built-in slots there's a slot types
there's a lot of them that that Amazon
provides that will do things like
provide you with dates and times and in
numbers so if it's a common type of
information data that you're trying to
get to chances are that there's a slot
type for it so you you want to look at
what slots are available built-in first
before you go creating your own and the
one that we're going to use for the QA
example is going to be a custom one and
the reason that we're going to use a
custom one is because the we don't know
what the values are that the user is
going to provide or what type and so in
this knowledgebase starter I've got a
custom type that is called question
values and this is what we're gonna use
for for our example but let's let's do
this
[Music]
let's see okay
let's how can we keep this simple as an
example why don't we just why don't we
just start with a simple example and
then we'll make it more meaningful just
to just to show you so I'm gonna go into
here and I'm gonna create a new handler
called let's see we'll say hello handler
just to show the slots
[Music]
and we're gonna create a new intent
called hollow intent and remember we
need to when we add a new handler we
need to register it so down here export
it and so there's that and now what else
do we want to do here so now what we
want to do is we want to set up in our
model we want to set up this intent and
in that intent we're going to let me
copy this we're gonna have a slot and
we're gonna prompt the person for their
name so let's do that here
[Music]
call this hello intent and
[Music]
we'll give it some examples uh Turin
says and just I'll stub it out first and
then we'll put a slot in there get rid
of this say hello
what is your name and let's build that
and push it out and we'll test it
[Music]
oops okay all right well that's building
I'm gonna look at the the questions if
anybody has any questions or thoughts
Karthik looks like you got them all okay
well we'll let that let that build here
for a second we're how are we doing on
time we got about 10 minutes so that
should give us plenty of time
[Music]
[Music]
okay
all right so that's all built so let's
um let's test it out just to see if
we're getting this this hello intent to
to fire Alexa open free code camp Alexa
open free code camp hello welcome to the
free code camp skill I can tell you
about recent medium articles or schedule
of live streams hello hello what is your
name
my name is Steve and you can see it's
not doing anything now because there's
no it's not waiting for a response and
it is not got a slot in it so that's
what we're gonna do now is we're going
to add a slot that is gonna collect the
name and this will be this will be an
example of a we'll use there's one built
in for first names and I'm gonna use
that one for this example so go in here
into my model and now I'm going to woops
[Music]
copying the right one
[Music]
okay all right so now I've added a slot
and the slot is named named the
parameter so now I can say hello
something like hello my name is Steve
well
name like that or hi I'm name or maybe
just like that and what I want to do is
well let's let me add the code so what I
want to do is when the user responds I
want to respond with something let's see
how I'm gonna do this let's go back over
here and what I want to do is I want to
grab the value of their name so I'm
going to get that from the handler input
and see so let's get rid of this now
[Music]
and so what's going on here is the I'm
setting up this variable name slot here
and setting it to the value of the the
the the the value that's coming over in
the Jason which is in the request that's
sent from the Alexa service and I'll
show you that in a second here and then
I'm including that or using that as part
of my response back so now I'm just
gonna say something like to test this
let's deploy it to test it I'll do
something like Alexa asked what Alexa
stop okay I've got a an error here let
me go back and fix that
[Music]
[Music]
all right let that finish deploying and
then we'll test it out and I think that
is probably as far as we're gonna go
today but let me know well this is
building if anybody has any questions up
to this point
I'm your question about using or
generating code through skill inator
aiyo I think that's a really good tool I
haven't used it in a little while but
for creating like just a end point that
you can use for testing I think it's
pretty awesome I'm pretty sure it's been
updated for the the 2.0 SDK but I
haven't looked at it recently I've used
it before though with the 100 SDK it was
so super helpful tool and there is also
I saw a question from somebody yesterday
about generating utterances I find it
I'll look again before the course is
over but there is a tool out there for
generating like utterance patterns it's
like a script and I can't I've got the
link somewhere I'll find that but and
post it but there is one out there let's
see so I think we can try this now we'll
see Alexa tell free code camp my name is
steeve Alexa stop goodbye Alexa tell
free code camp hello my name is Steve
hello my name is Steve thank you ok so
the the the dialog flan that's not super
smooth we've got to go back and clean
this up so that it makes sense you
wouldn't have somebody just going into
the launch and knowing you know that
they could say that their name is Steve
but we'll clean all of that up and again
I'll push this code out to a github repo
tonight so that for anybody that wants
it you can get it and tomorrow we're
going to
see what we are gonna talk about
tomorrow we're gonna talk a little bit
more about using slots just because I
kind of crammed it in at the end here
and I want to spend a little bit more
time on it and and then we'll get into
using custom slots and entity resolution
and this is where I'm gonna get into the
FAQ functionality and so we'll we'll
look again at the example in the
knowledgebase starter and then we're
gonna incorporate that into you into
here so that the user can get answers to
a lot of the the idea questions that we
got from yesterday and yeah and for
anybody that filled out the Google form
I'll also send out an invite to to test
the skill to beta test the skill so as
we're doing this you can test it on your
own echo if you want to do that so that
is it for today if anybody has any
questions I'll just I'll stay on and be
watching those thanks so much for
hopping on today and look forward to
hopefully seeing you again tomorrow
thanks so much
[Music]